joe biden and his wife dr
jill biden
the the most acclaimed surgeon
doctor doctor doctor
doesn't have an md or phd but she's a
doctor you and and
and
vindman is a lieutenant colonel
and jill biden is a doctor and damn you
if you won't use their proper titles
uh biden and jill got caught at a
restaurant in dc
not wearing the mask so they're walking
in the security detail they're wearing
the masks the staff members at the
restaurant
have the masks on
and someone there was filming this
happen from their table at the
restaurant and biden and his wife don't
have the masks on because
no serious person is worried about the
masks
including i'm not saying joe biden's a
serious person but he's serious enough
to know that the masks are just not that
big a deal
and so he walks in and it's so flagrant
i thought when i watched this i thought
joe biden must know that people have
cell phones joe biden must know that
people film him wherever he goes
dc has a very strict indoor mask mandate
dc forces you when you get to a
restaurant you have to put the mask on
then you walk to your table and then
you're allowed to take the mask off
you're in the bubble of protection and
then at some restaurants this actually
happened to me last time i was in dc
you the waiter comes to the table they
say excuse me sir while we're at the
table you need to put your mask on while
you're ordering i mean they're that
strict about it
and joe biden just doesn't wear it
and his wife doesn't wear it
doesn't he think he's going to get
caught
well the the sad answer is yeah he he
knows that someone's gonna film him he
just doesn't care
there's one set of rules for you
there's another set of rules for him and
what are you gonna do about it what are
you gonna do about it punk
you can't do anything joe biden man he's
the most popular president ever in
history he got 80 bazillion votes oh
yeah he got more votes than anyone ever
and he's super popular
and oh you're protesting him and
everyone's chanting let's go brandon and
he's
his poll numbers are tanking and yes so
what so what what are you gonna do about
it
at the moment very little at the moment
very little i'm so glad you enjoyed that
clip i liked it too i thought it was
good
the way i said that thing about that it
was really good you can get the whole
show here
at this youtube channel you ring the
bell you subscribe that's great or you
go to the michael knowles show at apple
podcast spotify stitcher google play
subscribe we really appreciate it really
helps us out to avoid some of the big
tech censorship issues
we'll see you over there and see you
next time
[Music]
[Music]
you